des bagages abandonnés orphelins on les
compte par centaines à l'aéroport
montréal-trudeau une valise bleue
alexandra bergeron est revenu de
vacances mercredi dernier six jours plus
tard il lui manque toujours une valise
on appelle arts canada on n'a aucune
réponse est personne nous dit trop quoi
faire cesser leur faire honnêtement que
l'on cherche à travers les valises
empilés tout le monde tout ni valises
ici ils ont juste envoyer les valises
sans les personnes s'étaient souvent
table
vous avez eu de la chance aujourd'hui
parce que vous avez récupéré vos 2e prix
un peu p j'ai trouvé les deux attaques
ce passage est arrivé de tel aviv
vendredi dernier vient tout juste de
retrouver sa valise à aux experts que je
pensais jamais la retrouver et je ne
m'attendais pas à la trouver comme ça
dans un coin empilés sous d'autres
valises puis comme si vous pouvez venir
ici vont venir n'attendez pas après les
compagnies aériennes l'industrie
touristique qui reprend ses activités à
vitesse grand v avec la fin des mesures
sanitaires est frappé de plein fouet par
une pénurie de personnel la situation a
créé un effet domino sur les différents
services air canada par exemple
transportent quotidiennement plus de 120
mille clients comparativement à 23 mais
il y en a la compagnie ajoute avoir des
problèmes avec son système de gestion
des bagages ce qui force l'annulation de
certains vols et des problèmes
d'acheminement
s'ajoute à la situation le manque
d'effectifs aux activités frontalières
jusqu'à 3000 agents supplémentaires
seraient disponibles je ne comprends pas
comment la situation alors qu'on en
mettant n'était pas 100% prévisible
ottawa promet d'intervenir en arène de
notre côté tout a été fait il faut
maintenant collaborer davantage avec les
compagnies aériennes et les aéroport
pour trouver une solution aux retards
des vols et la problématique des bagages
nous avons besoin de leur collaboration
affirme le ministre des transports pour
l'instant les voyageurs doivent s'armer
de patience
ici marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal